le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
les établissements scolaires sont certes
des lieux d'éducation mais ce sont aussi
des endroits où un élève passe une
grande partie de sa journée l'éducation
des enfants réunionnais est la priorité
du département et de sa présidente en
dix ans sept nouveaux collèges ont vu le
jour et 6 ont bénéficié d'importantes
réhabilitation pour cette nouvelle
rentrée une inauguration de taille a eu
lieu le 27 août dernier au tampon au
collège du 12e comment cet établissement
at il été accueilli quelles sont ses
spécificités
le sport at il sa place dans un collège
on en parle tout de suite dans lien
social
ouvert il ya tout juste un an le collège
du 12e au tampon méritait une belle
inauguration ce mois d'août pour cette
nouvelle rentrée attardons-nous pour
admirer cette merveille d'architecturé
mais pas seulement ce bâtiment est doté
d'un complexe sportif très important une
aire gazonnée un terrain de basket et de
volley une piste d'athlétisme un gymnase
tout juste terminée et très attendu des
élèves ainsi qu'un mur d'escaladé
les élèves pourront ainsi s'essayer à de
nombreux sports ce collège fait figure
d'exemple et force l'admiration de tous
pour ces classes ulis spécialement
adapté pour les enfants handicapés
aujourd'hui il est important que ces
enfants soient au contact d'enfants dits
normaux et vice et versa pour que chacun
grandissent de cette expérience mixte
anne marie est la représentante des
parents d'élèves au conseil
d'administration du collège de 12e et
représentante de parents d'élèves à
l'aps elle nous donne son avis et celui
des parents
une bonne dynamique avec un groupe de
parents d'élèves qui est on était dans
le conseil d'administration dont j'ai
été à la tête jusqu'à maintenant
jusqu'aux prochaines élections nous
avons pu réunir des parents qui sont
très motivés pour la scolarité de la
gamme 1 nous avons la chance d'avoir un
collège tout neuf nous avons eu la
chance d'avoir un collège qui a atterri
que des sixièmes chose qui est tout à
fait rare et à ma connaissance c'est une
première dans l'île et cette année nous
avons la chance d'accueillir des
cinquièmes par rapport à ce collège
c'est une réussite dans tous les points
en ce concept l'intégration car nous
avons la chance d'avoir un directeur et
le personnel enseignant et ducati qui
s'occupe également et ils font en sorte
que les élèves porteurs d'handicap
soient intégrés dans les classes normaux
et ça fait une très bonne chose et cela
n'est pas donné à tous les collèges donc
aujourd'hui ma satisfaction je pense que
c'est la satisfaction de tous les
parents
d'être tous les parents surtout qui ont
des enfants pendant dix capes et que
jusqu'à maintenant n'ont pas pu trouver
leur place virginie nous dit comment
elle a accueilli ce nouveau collège en
tant que parent
du coup c'est un gain de temps pas
possible pour les gens qui travaillent
sur fond il est magnifique face à
longvic
franchement c'est qu'on pouvait attendre
de mieux du moins sur le deuxième la
fille de virginie a vécu son intégration
avec enthousiasme
de cerveau qui avait pas aussi autant de
classes qu'à dans les autres collèges ça
l'a rassuré aussi
on a été très bien accueillie très bien
dirigés du quoi se sont rassurés et un
peu moins peur que je pense que les
obtiennent avec près de quatorze mille
naissances par an notre île à une
croissance démographique forte et donc
l'éducation est au coeur des
préoccupations car elle représente un
besoin de la population réunionnaise le
conseil général et sa présidente n'ont
pas hésité à investir plus de 20
millions d'euros pour que cet
établissement voit le jour pour qu'il
puisse correspondre à toutes les
attentes de cette jeunesse et aux
spécificités de chacun à terme cet
établissement accueillera très de 900
élèves tamponné et leur permettra de
travailler sereinement dans un
environnement propice à leur
épanouissement
la jeunesse réunionnaise et notre
oxygène et au conseil général nous
investissons sur tout ce qui est la
politique éducative nous aidons à la
construction des collèges nous équipons
un matériel informatique mais aussi en
mobilier tous les collèges de l'île nous
en avons construit sept nouveaux comme
nous en avons réhabilité certains mais
au delà même de ce que la loi nous
oblige nous mettons beaucoup beaucoup de
force à faire en sorte que les diplômés
et aussi les conditions pour faire des
études supérieures avec la bourse
départementale avec la location de
scolarité élevés avec les outils que
nous mettons pour que les jeunes
étudiants puissent se déplacer plus
facilement les voyages des collégiens
des collégiens le conseil général des
jeunes donc je crois qu'effectivement
pour assurer demain les meilleures
conditions d'intégration professionnelle
mais aussi d' intégration citoyenne de
chaque réunionnais le conseil général
nous donnons la meilleure égalité des
chances possible avoue aussi les jeunes
de vous donner vos propres moyens pour
construire votre futur
le tampon peut être fier de ce nouveau
collège les élèves comme mes parents y
trouvent l accueil et un enseignement de
qualité au milieu de structures
innovantes et ergonomique
l'environnement n'a pas été oublié dans
ce cadre scolaire afin que chacun ait la
possibilité de réussir un esprit sain
dans un corps sain voilà la vocation de
ce collège petit joyau du tampon il va
permettre de favoriser l'égalité des
chances et la diversité sociale au sein
des établissements scolaires et
contribuera à l'épanouissement de la
génération qui construira la réunion de
demain le conseil général de la réunion
vous a présenté lien social le conseil
général aux côtés des réunionnais